several people have been killed in a
shooting near a shopping center in texas
there were reports of multiple gunmen
using military-style weapons
police haven't ruled out that so far but
so many
have only arrested one suspect
at this second in time we have one
person in custody we won't rule out
multiple until we have a concrete
investigation
based on all the facts and investigation
of the scene so
it can change well ali joins me now
in the studio with the latest ali this
is very much an
uh evolving situation we're just hearing
the latest from the authorities there
what more can you tell us
yeah that's right so police were called
to cielo vista shopping mall in el paso
this is very near the mexican border in
the east
of texas um now there are reports there
were reports there was an active shooter
police still saying that this is
an ongoing active situation they say
they have reports of
multiple shooters on their twitter local
broadcasters reporting that there have
been
multiple fatalities now we don't know
the exact
numbers yet as you said there uh we
believe at least seven
people um but what we do know that there
has been a considerable response from
the authorities a considerable police
presence
we know that the mall was evacuated we
know that
the public had been urged to stay away
from the area unsurprisingly this has
all caused a lot of concern
and a lot of upset as the u.s faces up
to
yet another shooting and here was uh the
response from the former texan
congressman vito rook
there's a lot of injury a lot of
suffering
in el paso right now
i am incredibly saddened and it is very
hard to think about this
um
uh but i'll tell you um
el paso is the strongest
place in the world um
this community is gonna come together uh
i'm going back there right now
um to be with my family and to be with
my hometown
uh response from the mayor as well this
evening uh yeah that's right he's been
tweeting um he's just said i'll read you
briefly what he said my condolences and
prayers go out to all
of el paso as we mourn those impacted
by this tragedy and now to give you a
bit more details yellow
vista shopping mall it's the largest uh
shopping mall the largest of three
shoppings in the area
uh i'm sure that on a saturday afternoon
this would in all likelihood have been a
busy place for shoppers
on a saturday a metropolitan a built up
part of the city
and of course this comes less than a
week after
a gunman killed three people at a food
festival
in northern california before shooting
himself so for now details about this
latest shooting
are still coming to light but we know
that officers are
warning people to stay away from the
area this evening
these are live pictures that were just
getting into us here at sky news center
we understand as well that the president
has been informed he's been in touch
with the attorney general
for texas as well so all of the
authorities take this incredibly
seriously at the moment
unconfirmed numbers but at least one
suspect in custody ali forsky thanks
very much
indeed